Speaker 1: Republican Senator Lindsey Graham
was again overcome with emotion on television.
You might remember last week he was crying about
the pending arrest of Donald Trump. He was on Fox
News last night begging. People send Trump money?
Why you need to send a billionaire money. I don't
even understand. But here is Lindsey again. This
is starting to get a little bit embarrassing.
Speaker 2: I'm sorry I'm so upset, but please help
President Trump. If you could afford five or ten
bucks, if you can't afford a dollar five, just.
Speaker 1: If you make 28 grand a year,
if you can throw five bucks at this
billionaire to help him, please.
Speaker 2: Make sure you vote as early as
you can in your state. Don't risk anything.
Speaker 1: Oh, now early voting is good, huh?
Speaker 2: And getting more vote as soon as
you can. Pray for this country. Pray for this
president. And if you got any money to give,
give it. Lindsey Graham scum. It doesn't
go to me. It goes to helping this
president and taking back the Senate.
Speaker 1: Yep. Then he continues and
he says he set up a website for Trump.
Speaker 2: It's all crazy. Three great
pickup opportunities to give us the Senate
back in 2024. Three are Democrats in deep red
states that are up in 2024. We can take back the
Senate and President Trump can get a second term
to finish out his agenda. There's a lot of love
in the streets, but love ain't going to do it,
pal. They're trying to ruin this country. They're
trying to destroy President Trump. Tonight,
I have set up a website. I don't get one damn
penny, but I want you to give money tonight to
help President Trump. Yeah, he's raised 8 million.
Speaker 1: Remember to help him. What are you
donating to Trump's campaign? Are you
donating to Trump's primary campaign?
Is it money for the general? Is it money
that is for Trump's legal defense? Like
it? What are you donating to? Lindsey?
Speaker 2: This is legal garbage started.
Don't stop now. 70% of the money you give
tonight goes to help President trump. 30%
will help take back the Senate.
Speaker 1: To help him do what?
Speaker 2: I got a chance to pick up three Senate
seats in very red states held by democrats. And
I want to wake up after the election in 2024
with a Republican House or Republican Senate.
And Donald Trump raised his right hand swearing
to be the president of the United States that
we need. You are not helpless out there, folks.
Speaker 1: Yeah, really a dystopian vision. And
if you're saying didn't didn't Lindsey
just do this? Yes. Here is Lindsey last
week crying on Fox News about the indictment.
Speaker 2: How do you do it? You take a well,
if you've got a pile of crap and he
chop it up 34 times is still a pile
of crap is duplicitous charging. They're
trying to smear the guy. They're trying
to take cases that nobody else would take and
resurrect them. This is literally legal voodoo.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So the grift is fully back
and Lindsey is trying to take charge of it.
So there are, of course, so many questions
here. First of all, if Trump's a billionaire,
why does he constantly need money for everything?
He needs money because of Desanctis and he needs
money because of Joe Biden and he needs money
because of Alvin Bragg. And what's the money for?
Is it for the Campaign Legal Defense Fund? In this
case, Lindsey is saying for every dollar you give
through Lindsay's website, Trump gets $0.70 and
then $0.30 go to some kind of general pool for
Senate reelection campaigns or something like
that. This is Lindsey trying to get credit for
bringing money in Fundamentally. And as usual,
Trump likes his followers to the extent that
they're useful, and he went to them and gifted
them after the 2020 election saying, oh, we're
going to file all these lawsuits and forensic
audits and recounts. And it all went nowhere,
nowhere. But he gifted people who statistically
don't really have the money to be giving money
to Trump for this nonsense. He grifting them
to the tune of millions, tens of millions,
I believe it was. And now they're trying to do
it again. So my thought is, save your money,
save your money. Maybe put it in a savings
account, maybe get an index fund account going,
maybe put it in a 529. If there's a kid
who at some point might need an education,
don't give the money to Trump. It just doesn't
seem like the most useful use of funds. And this
is me advising people who don't like me, but
I don't want to see you grift it. All right.